[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذا من الطبيعي جدا نزول اسهم شركات
التقنيه خلال الايام الماضيه زي ما انتم
عارفين ان في مشاكل سياسيه وتضخم وغير
الاغلقات اللي قاعد تعاني منها بعض
المصانع
لكن في سبب اخر انه ارتفاع اسعار اسهم في
فتره كرونه كان جدا كبير بسبب الطلب
العالي على المنتجات التقنيه في فتره
كرونه اغلب الناس جالسه في البيت السفر
ممنوع ما تقدر تسافر ما تقدر تطلع من
المدينه الى انت موجود فيها هذا يشجع من
مبيعات الاجهزه بشكل جدا كبير ايضا لا
ننسى ازمه اشباه الموصلات اللي كانت في
بدايه السنه الحاليه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الشركات السيارات الكهربائيه تسلى كان
سعره سعرها جدا مرتفع لان كان تقريبا هي
الشركه الوحيده
الانصار في عده منافسين من الشركات صار
موجود قاعد يهدد مكانته في السوق ايضا
الشركات الالمانيه مرسيدس وغيرها من
الشركات الان صارت موجوده في الشركات
الصينيه قاعد تدخل وتقدم ابتكارات كثيره
وتقدم اشارات كثيره كل هذا قاعد يضغط على
السيارات الكهربائيه ايضا مع ضعف التصنيع
مشاكل التصنيع مشاكل صناعه البطاريات نفسك
على الشركه وقعت ياثر على تسليم السيارات
[موسيقى]